you're wrapping up a problem on this  yeah let's go ahead and start with  traffic you guys because it has been a  real nightmare that's a live picture of  the north 95 515 at eastern  it was shut down overnight let's go to  the traffic computer here because this  is part of what we call the big squeeze  you know we've been talking about that  with the backups that happen every day  but it's not every day that ndot  completely closes the freeway which they  did at 11 o'clock last night detouring  you off at las vegas boulevard up to  bonanza over towards mlk good news just  a couple of minutes ago the freeway did  reopen here's a live look these are the  cars that were backed up like a parking  lot so these are the southbounders that  was never affected  although it will be in the next couple  of days but let's concentrate on your  drive right now so back to that other  picture